a lot of the people we recruit are very
young so some of them are placement
students they're actually still at Uni
so some of them are barely turned 20 so
you know very young some of them are
grads as well but all of them are you
know below the age of 22. welcome back
to another episode of the recruitment
mentors podcast I'm your host teacher
mizzouz and on this week's episode I was
joined by Alex Morton from Timber seed
for the last two years she'd been
building her career within the SAS space
so in her first year at Timber seed she
was in a full 360 role and her best year
today has been
350 grand for the last year she'd been
in a role where 50 is team management
and then the other 50 has been new
business and account management you
start your recruitment career in 2016 in
education recruitment you was very much
you know building a desk from scratch
360 Temp and working with State schools
was difficult yeah uh in this episode we
really go deep into what world class
delivery looks like
how can we deliver an exceptional
candidate experience how can we drive
referrals how can we get more out of our
existing clients as well as this we go
into a really powerful functioning team
that Timber seed have which is the
research function utilizing it for long
list shortlist Market mapping you name
it as well as this we talk about
retained and how we've gone about
pitching that and so many other things
Alex did such a great job of breaking
things down in detail what you believe
are the common characteristics and
traits that make up a successful recruit
in today's market okay so I think just
from listening to the podcast a lot of
people have quite similar answers but I
think
enjoy this week's episode
Alex welcome to the podcast hi great to
be here thanks for making the trip yeah
actually not too far from your office
yeah literally five minutes away yes and
I really appreciate it looking forward
to this one I know that you um you know
you are very much involved in winning
business account management but when we
spoke I was really excited to really
delve into what makes world-class
delivery because I know that's been your
world in terms of whether that be uh you
know doing it yourself or managing
people in the delivery team so I'm
really excited to to go into that today
but I guess just to give everyone some
immediate context like I said anything
that I miss here that you think is
important pull me up on that yeah uh
internship at Michael page many years
ago is um
not many people not many people do that
I feel like I might be completely wrong
but I absolutely love that so internship
but Michael page then you start your
recruitment career in 2016
in education recruitment
um you was very much you know building a
desk from scratch 360 uh temp and
working with State schools was difficult
yeah it was tough time then you actually
went internal right yeah so it wasn't
actually internal so I was working for
Tes which is essentially like an edtech
company so they have lots of different
services that they provide to school so
there are quite loads of different SAS
products that they've sold to schools
but they also provided a recruitment
service so I kind of managed effectively
a delivery team okay so that's what I
wasn't sure wasn't quite internal but
yeah it's a bit confusing it's not your
typical recruitment yeah but still very
much educational recruitment but then
you've got this really cool exposure to
you know schools all over the world uh
International recruitment but like you
said it's still very much building on
that skill set of delivery candidate
experience placing people yeah then you
join Timber seed in September 2021
um and over the last uh yeah obviously
we're pretty much two years
first sort of months I think U.S full
360 right in terms of yeah doing the the
460 role obviously your world is SAS
startups particularly sdrs and startups
and early career opportunities and then
for the past year you've been in I think
we broke it down didn't we so the past
year about 50 of your role has been Team
Management yeah particularly
um managing a team of delivery
Consultants so you know that involves
one-on-ones uh there's about I think
five people in your team you also work
closely with someone called George who
is very much entirely focused on winning
business but then the other half your
job is split between new business and
account management yeah and then I think
first year at Timothy did 350. let's go
our best year in recruitment uh yeah
that was my best yeah yeah so yet to be
set but awesome cool
um so let's start with then the million
pound question I know that you hire
young people going into you know the
saswell but you also live and breathe
that for yourself so you hire a lot of
young people so talk to me about what
you believe are the common
characteristics and traits that make up
a successful recruit in today's market
okay so I think just from listening to
the podcast a lot of people have quite
similar answers you know there's the
resilience piece there's the the mindset
there's the work ethic so all of those
there's definitely a huge part of it
um but I think
well especially for our industry just
looking for people who are they they
really understand people so they can
read and describe people because what
we're looking for is not hard skills you
know we're not recruiting software
Engineers or people in finance so need
to have those hard skills we're looking
for people with those natural soft
skills so looking for people so when we
hire people we look for people who can
identify those kind of characteristics
they can actually read people I also
think people we like to hire people who
are good listeners so active listeners
so not just listening to respond
listening to understand
I think also a good eye for detail
definitely helps a lot just in terms of
the qualification process and
understanding all the roles that we work
on and I for detail just so you don't
you know leave any Stones left and and
turned
um I think a good memory as well I feel
like I don't know if that's mentioned
the podcast before but just that natural
ability to remember all the candidates
that you're working with all the jobs
like obviously you can have things
written down and you know on the
database Etc but having that memory is I
think that natural
yeah that natural skill that I think can
be developed but I think looking for
people who have that is yeah is really
key I really like the act of listening
piece something that I wasn't very good
at at the start of my career yeah I
think a lot of people just they can't
wait to jump in with their next question
like oh I've got a great question to ask
they're not really
probably not actively listening they
might you know be writing down notes but
they're listening to respond rather than
listening to understand yeah it's a good
way of putting that yeah I always
remember
early on in my recruitment career I'd
literally ask a question and answer it
for them somehow yeah or you just keep
talking I think recruiters love the
sound of their own voice a lot of the
time so you just keep waffling on and on
and on but eventually people stop
listening I think more is no so less is
more in in recruitment curious then with
those traits in mind what how does your
interview process look like because
maybe you've done some interesting
things that people could learn from like
do you have some interesting steps by
the the normal stuff do you get uh your
people to do certain activities and
tasks in between interview steps
anything to share there that has helped
uh you guys you know be confident these
people have those traits yeah so as you
said a lot of the people we recruit are
very young so some of them are placement
students they're actually still at Uni
so they're literally 20 some of them are
barely turned 20 so
you know very young
um so it was some of them are grads as
well but all of them are you know below
the age of 22. um so what we do is we
get them to record a one-way video
um so I think we used to use oddro and
now we use preview me so I think some
recruiters will use a lot of recruiters
will use those tools but it just gives
you an impression of you know how they
present themselves how they talk I mean
it's a bit awkward talking to yourself
on a camera so you know how they come
across and you know that energy they
bring I think that's that's really
important would you get them to talk
about just themselves really
um what's the prompt is it tell us yeah
yeah it's pretty basic to be honest um
like tell me about yourself
um why you want to work in Recruitment
and why Timber seed so I think showing
those research skills are really
important
so showing that the research so when
they actually come in for the interview
they need to have done a lot of research
on the industries that we recruit into
which is Recruitment and stuff sales
essentially so a lot of them have no
clue
um before they actually hear about Tim
so you know they're applying to loads of
different placements just whatever's on
the job board at University or whatever
the careers advisors talented to apply
to so that research is super important
so we verify that research when they
come in like they have to do a little
presentation
um we also get them to do a small task
when they come in so that could be like
a CV review task so look through these
series would you which jobs would you
which jobs to ex would you match them to
and why so it's just a really basic task
but I think showing their reasoning or
again them to explain their reasoning is
really important
we also get them to listen to some calls
um and describe that person's
personality and you know if they think
that basically score them out of 10.
obviously we don't say they candidate's
name or anything but they had to score
them at 10 and give that rationale as to
why they gave them that score so there's
a few different tasks because I think
just there's nothing really to go off on
their CV just where they went to UNI and
yeah maybe they worked in Tesco for a
few months but that doesn't really
matter it's about who they are as a
person so we're trying to draw that out
get them to show those core competencies
um rather than just you know their
background because that's pretty much
Irrelevant in in this job
um what else we do in the interview
process we also have to meet
pretty much everyone like it's a really
intense yeah it's a lot but it sounds
like it weirded out yeah we I think we
had about 800 applications to the year
in Industry last year just because you
know people apply to all sorts of stuff
it's not necessary people that are
genuinely interested in recruitment so a
lot of them are just not suitable
um but when they actually come in
they're here for about well they're in
the office for about five hours five
hours yeah well if they if they're good
if they're not very good they're
probably beat in and out in and out but
um yeah they meet all the Consultants
some of the current placement students
they meet the directors they meet me
who's like the senior manager some of
the other senior managers so they'll
even meet people like for marketing and
just to get different perspectives
because I think people have a different
idea
um of what's good and we're not just
trying to hire in our image we're not
just trying to hire people that are like
like carbon copies of us but they have
to be a good culture fit but I think you
don't want to just hire you know mini
me's
um we want people that bring different
perspectives so
and also to make it fairer I guess
um will go away and give them a score
privately so we won't discuss it we'll
give them the school we'll score them in
different categories so they're just
general demeanor their personality how
they come across their confidence their
their level of research their knowledge
about Timothy and our sectors there's
lots of different sort of categories
that we score them on and then we it's
kind of like an anonymous scoring system
then we come together and basically
score oh the manager the managers would
everyone everyone that met meets them
gives them a score so we kind of
calculate that and then people who have
the higher scores ultimately get the
offer so it's not just because I think
we used to we've changed this a lot
since I've been part of the hiring
process so we used to just kind of hire
on a Vibe yeah I can imagine yeah like a
lot of recruiters don't know there's no
there's no background really like you
might go oh have you if you've been in a
sports team and stuff like that yeah I
think any recruitment interview that
I've ever been a part of is just like a
chat yeah tell me about a time you've
demonstrated resilience you know it's
all the same really
um and they're good questions to ask but
I think you know when we're hiring
people that are that let's say they're
just placement students but they really
are the future of our business so the
the idea is that they do the placement
then they come back as a like more
senior consultant because essentially
they've had a year of recruitment
experience they go back to you and then
they come back so that's kind of the the
program that we try and run it doesn't
work for everyone not everyone wants to
come back not everyone wants to work in
recruitment for the rest of their lives
but some people we do get a few gems
that have come back and George was
actually one of them who was the the
guinea pig here in industry and he's
been here for like four years now so but
it also means when you are hiring those
types of people you're hopefully getting
the best of the the bunch rather than
just you know young person that can help
with like different tasks and take time
off people so just curious then just to
write that that's super interesting
thank you for sharing that
because there's a bunch of different
tasks there like the video piece the
presentation yeah it's a lot yeah
different people listen to calls
um from your perspective don't expect to
have the exact stats but how much do you
think that's impacted like attrition and
people being and like people being good
out of Interest by having that sort of
system
um in terms of people that return after
their year and into your people that
just for the year placement people
um so it is for grads as well right yeah
so all I mean we've hired a few
I say grad some of them have been
graduated for like a year but it's their
first job in recruitment so they're all
still here I think that process has yeah
helped with when you hire people like
that absolutely yeah everyone that we've
hired since I
think we've hired about five people
since I started one one of them left
after a year to go to another
recruitment job
um but they're all still here and
they've all received at least one
promotion since they've been here yeah I
love that
appreciate you sharing that let's just
go into then like world-class delivery
because I'm excited to dive into this so
I know your first year was very much 360
and it wasn't
um just delivery but yeah Keen to go
into this review because of the team
that you manage so would you mind just
sharing like the setup at Timber seed
because this may not be you know normal
for every single team there's definitely
plenty of recruitment organizations out
there that have people that just you
know are Hunters that go out and win new
business then have a delivery team that
support them on delivering you know
hiring projects and different things but
would you mind just starting by saying
by sharing like your team your like unit
and like the setup and then we can go
into it yeah so I think Timber seed is a
bit different than a lot of recruitment
companies I mean I haven't worked in all
recruitment companies so I don't
actually know this for certain but I
think the the actual recruitment process
is split into three so we have three
different areas of specialism so we
obviously have people like me and George
who are sort of winning new business
it's more the client-facing side so I
guess that could be classes 180 we still
do about candidate delivery but you know
now and then if it's a more senior
candidate and then we have
the delivery team that are purely
focused on speaking to candidates
qualifying candidates managing them
through through the process they don't
actually do any of their own sourcing we
have we kind of outsourced the um what
we call them the research function and
they're based in our office in Warsaw so
their job is to essentially Source
candidates build its Market mapping
building out those different networks
that we kind of head hunt from within
because we don't use job boards or
anything like that most of the most use
job boards don't use job boards
entry-level Talent really no job boards
yeah so we operate like a almost like a
executive search type company you know
we're Market mapping building out that
graduate Network every year so we have
multiple different networks we've got
you know your bog standard graduate
Network like that's split into lots of
different
subcategories like Russell group you
know Oxbridge and sort of non-russell
group and then we've got the bilingual
Network as we a lot of the SDR hires
that we do speak a second language like
for the German market French market Etc
um and then we have like sort of
slightly more experienced candidates and
building up so the researchers in Warsaw
I mean it's such a like incredible
function that we have like I don't know
how I used to operate without a function
like that but it's a big engine room of
constantly sourcing candidates and these
people are being contacted all the time
not necessarily about one specific job
it's not like we get the job and we go
and find the person sometimes we do work
reactively like that but we're kind of
proactively building out that Network
reaching out to graduates messaging them
about our opportunities and educating
them on the jobs because I'd say 90 of
graduates don't know what an SDR yeah
exactly is so that's a big part of what
we're just constantly doing in the
background so just curious then just
quickly what so if I'm a delivery person
deliver consultant sorry delivery
consultant in that delivery function
love really like that's super smart on
the the research front I absolutely love
that
what are like the deliverables so what I
mean by that is if I'm a delivery
consultant what is my researcher giving
me if you get what I mean so I
understand that they're always then you
know consistently building these Talent
communities from you know from a Timber
speed perspective not necessarily like
pitching people jobs but just always
growing that Network and always growing
you know the people that could
potentially be at some point interested
in the career in SAS sales but like what
what are they providing the delivery
consultant like to get what I mean so
like they're getting like every week
it's like hey guys we've you know
there's these bunch of
um graduates that have really come onto
LinkedIn or what I don't know what what
are like the deliverables
um it's CVS and calls booked so amazing
calls books yeah so they will sometimes
have so we'll constantly be building up
that Network that's on our database and
we'll normally reach out to those people
through
um we'll sometimes set them up on like a
source well okay like an email Cadence
or just mail merge them directly so we
get their series back from that um so
they're kind of kind of sitting in our
database and then there's the kind of I
guess fresh candidate so straight from
LinkedIn that might be there could be a
grad or someone with a bit of experience
generally we work on roles like not to
five years of experience so they have to
put a call into the consultant's diary
um so number of calls booked number of
CB sent although a lot of what we do
we've kind of changed how we target the
researchers because it's not there there
is a very different skill type it's
obviously very research heavy it's not
we're not hiring recruiters we're not
looking for that kind of competitive
resilient type person like we're looking
for smart people who have like that
either for detail enjoy those kind of
nitty-gritty research tasks building
those Talent lists those long lists and
recent researching the the the network
on on LinkedIn so we normally
um sort of Target them on time spent on
a particular activity so it could be two
hours spent as they also help with the
market mapping for BD collecting leads
so could be in the morning they have two
hours spent collecting leads to pass on
to me and George and then we can then
reach out to them in the afternoon it
could be two hours spent on a specific
project for example we've got one of our
clients who are opening up a new office
in Germany so we're
um sort of I guess adding people
collecting with people who are based in
Munich for that job so they'll have
specific projects that they're working
on and then they'll have the general
day-to-day you know collecting leads
messaging people asking for their CV
about a particular role posting job ads
on LinkedIn
um so loads of different activities that
they do they also help build our salary
benchmarking reports uh industry like
hiring reports so all the we do like a
quarterly movers and levers report so
it's all that added value that the
delivery team or you know me as a sort
of manager we don't have time to do all
of that people but a lot of people are
expected to do that or like those things
that you just said that
pretty important task to do to be
successful yeah yeah when I joined Tim
said I couldn't believe it I was like oh
so I just speak to clients and that's
pretty obviously I manage people as well
but I was like you know a lot of that
it's very time draining activities
sometimes that kind of Market mapping
you know the messaging people and so how
big is that research team oh I think
it's oh it's grown like massively since
I joined so roughly 20 people yeah 20
researchers how many people do you think
um so it's I'd say the office is a kind
of evenly split so actually probably
just less than 20 about 18 and then
we've had about 15 in the London office
yeah so about 18 people support 15
people okay and they also support the BD
element to not just okay cool yeah okay
super interesting then so so that that
so that's this so that's the split
basically you've got the the people that
are very much entirely focused on
getting in front of clients you know
winning hiring projects people that are
then so the delivery Consultants buy
this stuff all the stuff that you just
mentioned
what are like the key things for them
then are they yeah like qualifying
candidates all these types of things
what are like the the core elements that
a delivery consultant does so the
metrics that we kind of Target them on
on a weekly basis is well kpis I guess
like the number of calls that they do
daily so you know 50 60 calls a day like
they get through high volume because the
work we're doing is is kind of high
volume low value because it's more entry
level stuff so um yeah a number of calls
they're doing number of seat candidates
qualified a number of CVS sent out to
the clients they sent to us and then
we'll obviously quality check everything
and make sure they're good enough to
send to the client and what else they
have to obviously the number of
interviews that are arranged as a result
of that that's what they're targeted on
so
um yeah their job is just to speak to as
many people as possible per day to find
those Diamond candidates basically okay
cool
so talk to us about how you've got
better at quality checking so I mean a
huge part of what I do is listening to
people's calls so listening to the
delivery Consultants calls they have to
send me their qualification calls so
that could be a phone call or often will
record like the video qualification call
which is like a more in-depth like
second call so I won't do that for every
kind of because I'll be literally there
24 hours a day listening to calls
um but I yeah I listened to the calls
normally on high speed so I'm just like
Yeah because it takes too much time so
what I'll do is I'll provide feedback to
the consultant so I normally use I think
it's called like the gar method so
what's good what points you need to
action and the remedy for that so I'll
say okay what was good about this call
is you did this this and this you Dove a
bit deeper into like potential counter
offers you ask them about the interviews
you know that's you know great
qualification call what you didn't speak
about is
I don't know they're relocating you
didn't really dig into into that in any
depth uh the remedy for that is okay
next call you need to sort of ask them
about the logistics relocating so it's
like what what was good what could have
been better and the remedy for that so
you give an actionable feedback rather
than and just free simple bullet points
yeah rather than uh yeah it was all
right you could have done better you
could have dug a bit deeper and they're
like okay what on specifically like you
know so I think it's that kind of
reflection giving them feedback
um so I'm obviously quality checking
that for the client
um we track data across everything so
every candidate will track all different
types of data whether they're you know
male female what kind of University they
went to the degree classification
location all that kind of stuff I'll
make sure that's all all tracked um and
then just the general quality checking
of how we're presenting the candidates
to the client so how we're how we're
selling them because they're normally
graduates without much experience what
experience are we drawing out and what
we highlight into the what's important
to the client making sure the delivery
team really understand that because then
they're not on every client meeting so
making sure we're all singing from the
same him sheet making sure I'm recording
the client calls if they're not on it
getting them really involved in in that
um so so what they are so they can
understand like the culture what's
important to them what makes that
business different yeah exactly et
cetera yeah because one
one company is very different from the
next what they're looking for from an
SDR is so different so it's not like a
one-size-fits all you can't just fling a
CV out to five clients and you know hope
for the best so it's really they need to
really understand the
the sort of yeah the uniqueness of each
client and each job so you quality check
by making sure that you do consistent
coaching on them getting better at
qualifying candidates essentially yeah
so but then in terms of the process then
they've got someone they did the video
call you they then say hey Alex this
person I think would be perfect for
ex-clion and then you're like yep I
agree and then you then get and then you
present them to the client yeah it works
yeah pretty much yeah and a lot of the
time they might not be suitable or we
don't have anything for them so we think
okay let's create a plan of action for
this particular candidate if we think
they've got potentially yeah sure
curious then done anything smart on
presenting I feel like you know the way
that you guys do things it so have you
found anything because like you said
you're presenting people that has a like
like a lot of the time haven't got like
the previous experience to say this
person has worked as an SDR for the last
two years hitters hit their quota for
you know X percent so like you do you
know I mean you haven't got as much of
that so how are you presenting these
people who you're really drilling into
on their characteristics and like the
culture fit and you know these things
have you done anything smart they're in
presenting these people yeah I mean I
don't think we've reinvented the wheel
yet on that I think there's probably
smarter ways that we can work so we do
it in very straightforward way we you
know we normally do like a candidate
write-up we just do a few bullet points
based on who the other person and draw
out those
um I guess those competencies where they
might have demonstrated elsewhere like
in competitive sport or you know being
president of some Society University I
say most of the graduates that we
represent are they're like the elite
level graduates in terms they've done
tons of internships they've had loads of
client customer facing roles they're not
just your bog standard graduates so
drawing presenting that experience and
addressing things that might be a red
flag so sometimes
um like so if someone studied a degree
in law why do they want to be an SDR
like the client will just look at that
and think no and if that person had
applied to an advert directly they would
have just immediately been rejected
because you've got no relevant
experience done a law degree like how is
this relevant so I think really
articulating in a very simple way why
they are relevant and why they are right
for that company using those kind of
buzzwords that the client has relayed to
me on what they're looking for that sort
of resilience someone who can explain
quite a technical Concept in you know
really engaging way like that kind of
person somebody's got the right kind of
raw soft skills for sales we do also use
video presenting sometimes sometimes it
depends what
I mean yeah if it's a new client and
they they really want to kind of see
what our candidates are like before
sort of entering that partnership with
Timothy then sometimes we do that
um I'd say most the time I present like
an initial shortlist of candidates
whilst I'm on a call with a client so I
talk through why we think they're good
why we think they've got potential on
live on a call so we'll look through the
the candidates together because it's so
easy to dismiss a CV just for not being
relevant totally yeah okay that's that's
really interesting and then I guess just
on the final bit on the the delivery
concerns then if you've done a lot of
coaching where where has often been
where people like slip up or you find
yourself
what have been what's been the most
consistent remedies you know what I mean
I think that might be helpful for people
the most consistent like what have you
found yourself repeating yourself on
whether it be you know even the
placement year or younger people that
you were helping last year to this year
what's always ended up being the things
that you've really tried to drill down
on for them to get good at quickly which
would be really you know helpful because
I'm sure there's something that they
always make people typically fall short
and it might be just digging deeper or
like just being order takers but like oh
yeah you want to relocate to London okay
cool great and then on to the next
question I don't know if there's
anything that you've found that
sometimes people just sometimes slip on
slip up on yeah I think a lot of people
especially when there's pressure to fill
jobs like we're saying to them every day
we need more CVS for this job we need
more candidates and they're like oh I
need to get more candidates so they can
skip things so not cutting Corners so
sometimes I go back over their
qualification and there's lots of things
that they've missed I think also not
just hearing what you want to hear so
someone might come across well you know
the bubbly the bright Etc but do they
really want occurring in as an SDR like
do they really know how tough it's going
to be can they really deal with that
rejection so getting them in that second
qualification Call to
um demonstrate come the candidates to
come with examples of why they've
demonstrated that so not just hearing
what you want to hear with the candidate
because sometimes a candidate will be
like yeah they want a job basically
they're a graduate they're sitting at
home on on the sofa they're like I just
want a job so they'll tell they're
speaking to recruitment Consultants
who's their age and they're like yeah
like this sounds great but it's you know
do they really want that so it's about
having that I think it really comes from
experience it's digging deeper and
understanding what the candidates really
want what what are their values when it
comes to a job like what why are they
doing this is it because they want to
buy a house or support their parents or
are they just a really competitive
person like really digging deeper into
who these people are as a person not
cutting Corners in the qualification and
yeah just not not just hearing what you
want to hear yeah I love it
commission structure then how have you
approached that how have you structured
that we've had people on the podcast
before where
I think often times the little like when
you say I'm a delivery consultant that's
viewed as uh not as good as a 360
consultant yeah so sometimes that can be
reflected in how people are incentivized
like we've had people on the podcast
before where they had to change the
commission structure because the
delivery function which they literally
described as the engine room of the
business
um were earning it's probably too much
less than compared to the people that
were doing like bringing on the clients
and these things but they were the
people you know providing the shortlist
and the candidates
so how have you approached that curious
how have you structured what you know
what people get how much of the the
placements goes to the delivery
Consultants how does that work yeah well
first of all I've never really
understood that kind of you know there's
so much emphasis on you know we need
good BD consultants and they're often
like put on a pedestal and I kind of get
that obviously you can't fill the job if
you don't have the jobs and that is a
skill in itself especially you know it's
more kind of experience and school
Consultants tend to do that but the
delivery is such a skill in itself like
if you win the jobs and you can't
deliver on them then what's the point
like you're just disappointing your
clients so I think in my eyes they're
equally as important as one of their two
sides of the same coin but in terms of
commission so if someone's on a
placement you know they're doing an
internship so they don't get the same
commission structure as like a permanent
consultant so they'll get like a bonus
per placement which can be anything from
200 pound per placement to 500 pound
depending it's like a scale of you know
there's different thresholds permanent
Consultants it's 50 50. really yeah so
if for example if I bring on or if
George brings on a client and then the
the delivery consultant if their
permanent member staff fills that then
it's split 50 50. so yeah we kind of put
equal emphasis on we reward them equally
um some of the placement students as
well they go on to that permanent
commission structure before the end of
the year if they're doing really well we
want to reward them because they are
treated the expectations are so high for
these placement students that we want to
reward them if they're good they've got
potential we reward them and then they
come back and they're on they're on that
same commission structure as a permanent
okay well they come back as a permanent
member of staff and it's 50 50. this
podcast is proudly partnered with
vincere the all-in-one recruitment
agency software that over 20 000
recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning one-up
sales sales and motivation platform that
enables you to maximize the potential of
your teams we love partnering with both
of these organizations because they
share our mission in helping you get the
most out of your people and your
business you can get exclusive offers
because you listen to this podcast and
get up to 10 of the usage price forever
use a link in the show notes to get your
hands on that let's get back to the
episode so let's talk about like I know
we weren't really granted they're there
but there's so many like interesting
things on people thinking about the
delivery function how to set it up how
to approach it love the researcher
insights in there as well I think that's
so powerful and I'd be surprised if more
and more companies don't try and at
least build a function like that because
it's so powerful and time consuming yeah
so to have people dedicated to that it's
so powerful like if we were to talk
about new business then which I know
you've
um
had to do more and more of more recently
let's bring the delivery function into
it like how has them having these two
functions a delivery consult the
delivery function the researcher
function how has that then how do you
feel that has then impacted yours and
George's sales process or ability to
sell like because that because I feel
like that that would be I'd be really
excited to get in front of clients and
say
well this is how we work we have our
research and function who are doing this
we have our delivery Consultants that
are doing this it's not just hey I'm the
consultant you should be speaking to I
only speak to sdos all day every day
like you should trust me to fill this
position like I will yeah I mean like
that that how does that impact your
sales price because I feel like that
could be pretty powerful yeah well I
think first of all it's free to it frees
up a lot of our time to focus on
bringing on high value clients I mean
there's tons of SDR jobs out there even
now we're seeing the market shift
there's even more jobs being advertised
I think it it was a bit of a lull like
earlier this year but
um yeah it frees up a lot of our time it
gives us a lot more confidence when
we're going into that delivery so that
um like Discovery call with uh with a
prospect
um I normally split the discovery call
into two parts so there's the initial
maybe 30 minute chat understanding a bit
more about their business goals you know
if they've received recent funding what
are they using that funding for like how
does this hire fit into that bigger
picture of the business goal well it
depends who you're talking to but you
know whether it's an SDR manager or a
cro that you're going to want to
understand their role in the business
and and the goals that they're trying to
meet you know is it they need to hit a
certain ARR by next year and how is this
you know building that SDR team going to
fit in with that so understanding their
business goals some of the issues that
they've had around hiring whether it's
time
uh budget or equality all that kind of
stuff all the usual stuff and then in
the second more sort of in-depth
Discovery call would um understand the
specification a bit more detail and kind
of map out that process and we can be
really granular with mapping out that
process although it's people think entry
level jobs it's just you fire a few CVS
over and it's you know the jobs filled
but we still take time to kind of it's
almost like project management good
deliveries project management so we work
with the we kind of describe how we how
we work how we're different not going to
sorry it's about inverse so just do you
so you said Discovery recall there one
not every recruiter knows what that is
by the way more like conducts those just
it's a lot so do you split so when you
said Discovery called business goals is
that a separate call and then you say
okay well from what you shared from what
I've learned today
we've helped companies like yours these
are some of the companies that we've
helped so I'd actually really recommend
that we're booking a further time where
we can go through Timber seed how we
work how we're different and you know
how we could potentially help you
achieve X so like do you separate it
yeah exactly so I'd probably spend maybe
five minutes at the end of that first
call just talking about just giving them
a very brief background on Timber seed
and wire this is they're trying to
conversation is relevant qualify them in
in that yeah I'm not trying to sell like
sell them Timber seed really I mean a
little bit I am but um okay so yeah
that's the first part of the sales
process is that this this discussion
initial Discovery yeah just curious then
how uh how would you what is the
personal Discovery call in your point of
view um I think it's to really
understand those pain points and dig
deeper into those because sometimes
there's pain points that they don't even
realize that they've had that you're
uncovering
um so making them kind of understand
that pain and how we could be a solution
to the problem that they have
um and yeah I think just really
understand how this higher that we're
going to help them with is going to help
them meet those goals is a lot of making
them realize things almost sometimes
educating them on sometimes they think
they need one thing but actually we've
worked with other companies where
something else has been more successful
so sometimes for example a client will
come a prospect will come to the same we
need an SEO with two years experience
it's an entry-level job but we need to
use experience so
um so making them understand that it cut
someone with you don't need that
experience you need someone with the
right potential and is gonna kind of
grow with the business how so how do you
sell how do you sell the discovery call
when you've got a client that's
basically saying to you and other
recruitment companies Alex I've got I
need to we need to get to a million
annual requirement revenue and in order
to do that I have a um I have you know
five SDR seats that we need to have
filled sap here are the job specs can
Timber seed help like how are you like
because I spoke to
someone who operates in in your space
Lewis we're talking about this and their
process in a sense sometimes like these
people just want like Alex can you just
you know start getting CVS over to us
and and like just start working on these
opportunities for you to then go you
know no no hang on a minute we need to
have a discovery call you need to tell
me about your pain about your challenges
and then we'll have another call where
we can talk about how we can help how do
you navigate that just curious curious
yeah I mean it's it's tough to find that
balance because the sense of urgency you
need to have that commercial awareness
that these jobs need to be filled well
the clients in the job needs to be
filled so sometimes it can almost send
you into a bit of a panic like we need
to see these nails but um I think just
taking a step back and
we can still have a very quick
turnaround time so just helping them to
understand what those next steps will
look like the realistic time frame if
they're saying we need people to have
started yesterday okay well
you know what's the next best thing you
know because people generally if they're
in a job they're going to have a notice
period or they might you know it's going
to take you at least two weeks to do the
interview process so helping them to
understand what that time frame would
look like and we've got candidates
normally ready to go we've got because
of our delivery function we've got a
bank of really strong candidates who
we're kind of representing so I can say
okay we can book in that second call
tomorrow where we can go through these
active candidates as well as mapping up
the process so kill two birds with one
stone it doesn't have to be a long drawn
out process you know we're not
recruiting for CFO here we're we're
recruiting Junior people so well you can
have both you can have the in-depth
Discovery and a deep understanding of
the client's need whilst
um providing that kind of quick service
for them so yeah you can have both would
you say would you say no would you not
work with a customer if they weren't
willing to the Discovery call
yeah I feel like I wouldn't yeah I
wouldn't work with them would you say
like no like this is what this the
reason why we have this process is if we
do this it's going to help us in the
long run sort of thing so yeah I mean I
haven't not for it hasn't happened for a
while where people have kind of refused
to take that time and obviously people
are extremely busy in the businesses
that we speak to and everyone's busy all
the time but
um I think just helping them to
understand the value of that
conversation if they don't have time
they just want me to fling a few CVS
over then I'll just say no I can send
them some a case study and some example
candidates of people would Place
recently so they can have a look before
they decide to go through with that call
but
um yeah it needs to be a partnership
yeah I know I love that so then do the
discovery call we learn about their
challenges what they've tried so far
their business goals what might prevent
them from getting there you have all
that information
how do you then use that information in
the next chord and like what what's
fundamental in this next call on the on
the sales process
um so aside from going through like the
candidate role specification because
it's not always exactly yeah a job brief
all of that kind of stuff
um but I think sort of almost playing
back their problems to them so in our
previous call you mentioned this this
and this sometimes I'd even almost do
like a mini presentation of okay these
are the issues you haven't this is how
would solve it and these are the
candidates I think would be a good fit
be good to get your feedback
um so yeah I think just going through
things in a bit more more depth in that
Discovery course or playing back the the
previous call and mapping out the next
service
as part of that do you because I know
you've been working a lot more retained
do you have different products then that
you sell and present in that yeah so we
actually created a product because
obviously we sell into the SAS sector so
they can relate to having like a product
so recruitment isn't normally seen as a
product it's a service so but we try to
make it kind of relatable to people in
in SAS sales so we kind of created this
product that we call CX plus so client
experience plus so we have like a
product document that we created
um with like a pricing sheet and other
things just so they can be like okay
this is like what we sell
um in a way
um so we kind of present that to them so
that's our kind of retained service
these are all the extra things you get
as a part of that
um compared to compared to uh contingent
exclusive yeah we tend not to work it
depends really depends on the situation
the role the scope of work that it's
going to take us
um and then we'll kind of weigh it up
whether it's something if they really
don't want to go retained on that first
roll because it's completely brand new
for them sometimes they don't want to do
that
um but just highlighting the importance
of that exclusivity and how it's going
to benefit them rather than oh we want
you to be exclusive with us because it
makes our life easier like they don't
care what what's in what's in customer
experience plus that isn't them
exclusive
um so I think it's just
having that more structured process
that's one of the things we'll still
structure that process in in exclusive
project but it won't be as much of a
priority like we weren't spent as much
time having these kind of check-in calls
and presenting candidates like we'll
have a set date to have a long list it's
like okay we'll work on it and we'll try
and get your candidates ASAP whereas
it'll be much more structured process as
CX plus they also get
um a priority with the the market
mapping report so the the moving the
movers and levers reports they also get
the
um like salary benchmarking reports
um and they also get access to like like
discounts for like sales trainers and
stuff like people in our Network we'll
introduce them to and they'll get a
discount on that
um oh wow so you've you've like created
a whole thing around it yeah exactly and
they also yeah and it depends on what
they're looking for so if it's like a
key hire
um there's different like pricing
packages if they're looking for like a
we call it a key High that's like one
person or a team build team build then
they get some kind of maybe incentive on
that like a slight discount as they're
looking to hire like five people at once
do you do anything around because you
have all that data on do you do anything
around like you're creating them like a
because when we've asked when I've asked
people about this what's quite common is
you start working with them and you're
presenting them the candidates you've
spoken to the reputation in the market
You're Building like a bit of a talent
pool might be on a spreadsheet or
whatever do you sort of do something
similar to that where you're always
building that showcasing that with them
in the checking calls and that's data
that they get to keep yeah absolutely so
we'll build that initial long list of
people these are people in our Network
we're just going to reach out to yeah
they can keep that
um and like the market insights
um but yeah just there's generally just
a lot more touch points in in that
process and a lot more
sort of feedback throughout the process
as well any was it difficult for you to
start selling that if you hadn't worked
like that before oh yeah I've been a
contingent recruiter my whole life it's
a mindset shift for sure it's having
confidence in what you're selling is is
you know it's a necessity for for them
and it's a high quality product so and
we're still we still have challenges
with this because some hiring managers
will say well we've never worked like
this before like why do you need a
return there's it's a whole
sort of re-education type thing and my
mind mindset shift within yourself and
having confidence in going out there and
selling that service so yeah I'd still
we're still ironing out that that
process is definitely not perfect and I
think it's more about
it will evolve over time and you kind of
build confidence with that once you've
won a few retained projects then they
all seem to come at once it's like buses
float it's
um but getting that first few is is the
biggest challenge
and how does it what do you then do when
you're pitching a customer
you're pitching them to work retained
but then they speak to one of your
competitors and they don't go retained
they don't they're not pitch and
retained and then they go with them well
they're frustrating right yeah it can be
frustrating it does happen but then it's
probably we've got to look at how well
we've sold
uh product and our service
um and maybe they're just not the right
client for us like we're really picky in
the the type of companies we work with
so we're assessing whether they're the
right fit for us whether they're in our
ICP whether it's someone we can see
ourselves partnering with and vice versa
and if they think another agency is a
better fit for what they want and
they're they're just looking for the the
cheaper option or they're just looking
to save money then obviously that's
their priorities we're not the cheapest
like we're never going to be the
cheapest so
um if they want that if they want a
different style of service that's going
to work for them then that's absolutely
fine there will be other customers out
there that this does work for them
and just interested then what because
I'm sure you thought more and more about
this if you as you've refined it what
have you found that your customers have
found to be the most valuable bar
getting the people placed and in the job
you know the things around it like what
have you found that they've gone you
know what yes you know Timber seed help
us get our SDR team which is absolutely
amazing but they also provided this and
we absolutely [__] loved that has
there been anything quite common that
you've found that they've really
appreciated out of those the things that
make the whole offer
um I think the market insights and the
market mapping and presenting that to
them because they don't really have an
understanding of the talent pool all
they can see is who's applying to their
job adverts and you know some months
it's we've got loads of people applying
some months there's no no one applying
so understanding
um yeah just having that kind of insight
into more insights I think is what they
find valuable
wow we've gone into a lot of details
aren't we yeah you've wrote that down so
so well though yeah and I'm by no means
an expert in retained recruitment it's
still very neat it's a whole learning
that you shared there it's more about
like I've been on my own Journey with
this I sell a training product it's a 12
month contract and I've really for
anyone that really wants to dive into
this I don't know if you've come across
this content but like I'm a huge fan of
um Alex or Mosin it has this book called
100 million offers and basically it's
all centered around creating like an
offer that you feel stupid saying no to
and is it all centered around
uh you know having products that solve
the product and the problems that you
know your customers likely have and
that's obviously what you're doing right
you're yep people problem but then also
you know insight and understanding
problem of are you paying the right
things
um do you have the right benefits um
also
um you're probably going to want to get
these people up to speed so we've also
got trainers that you can tap into so
like you're you're like crafting that so
that's like really helpful because at
the end of the day a retain piece like
if you are going to consistently sell it
it isn't about you and getting money up
front and that being great for you it's
about what how it is for the other
person receiving around what problems
are you solving for them yeah and that
needs to be evident when you're
presenting that and during the discovery
like it can't be like okay well this is
just better because it is like you need
to really make the make sure they
understand the impact the positive
impact for them
um you know all about the the general
experience for them the impact you know
these people are probably going to say
longer if we you know if we take this
approach you're gonna have better
retention like yeah all of that kind of
stuff yeah exactly I think a lot of
recruiters don't see themselves as
salespeople and I didn't really see
myself as a salesperson before I started
at Timothy and I started working in the
sales sector so even like just
understanding like look sales thought
leaders following them there's obviously
a lot of information out there's lots of
books but trying to see yourself as a
salesperson and you know start reading
these books and following these people
like sometimes it can be a bit
overwhelming but just taking inspiration
from that not just okay how do I recruit
well it's how do I sell yeah solve
problems be outcome Focus solution
focused yeah I love it so for people
listening then that
okay so let's just sort of round this
episode out with with these uh one or
two last thoughts then I know we haven't
covered actually everything we want to
speak about but I feel like the things
that we have spoken about will be so
helpful for people so I guess firstly if
you were to uh for people listening that
may not have a delivery function or like
a function that is solely focused on the
candidate part of that recruitment
cycle uh if you were to you know build
that team from scratch how would you go
about that like what would be the the
fundamental things that you would go
about getting in place
at the start to really hopefully have
the best chance of this delivery
function delivering as quickly as
possible out of Interest that's a tough
question because I've never built a team
from scratch
um okay so why don't instead then what
do you think like for people listening
to run out what are like the fundamental
things that you think need to be in play
to make a delivery function like
successful and for it to be the engine
room
um so what we've found effective this
time around because we're quite lucky in
that we always get to do things again if
we're hiring placement students
obviously the permanent members of staff
are you know they're they're here
they're part of the furniture but we
always get a fresh start every year so
what we've helped what's helped this
year in building this delivery function
from scratch is having what we call it
the timber seed Bible like the delivery
Bible so having all of our processes in
place and making sure they're trained on
okay this is the timber seed way so
having those processes in place before
you start bringing on the people so from
day one they're very aware of yeah the
Playbook yeah so
um what goes in what are some of the
things in the Playbook well it's about
this thick so a lot of potential print
out yeah we printed it out which was
yeah it took forever but we also have it
on you know on Google Docs but
um so what is it like this is how we
qualify our candidate this is how you
add them to the system yeah literally
everything it was painstaking to make so
me do you make it so me my colleague
Anna who manages the other delivery team
um and Khalia who helps with the kind of
onboarding
um so it was kind of a joint effort but
um and it took ages but now we've got
that and we can keep adding to it you
know it's a live document that is gonna
I'm Gonna Keep so we put in we also help
them to understand from day one what
obviously what their targets are but
what does performance look like and what
does the bare minimum look like so
there's always these kind of
yeah I guess the sort of yeah the upper
Mark and and the lower Mark what
excellent looks like what kind of you
know just standard looks like
um and helping them to understand that
from day one so the expectations are
really clear I think when hiring young
people or new people who are new to
recruitment you can't underestimate the
value of structure in the job so I think
when I was in my previous role I used to
when I was doing like one-to-ones Etc I
used to let the one-to-ones just run
like we'll just have a chat you know how
are you getting on any problems Etc but
now I have an agenda we have a structure
um and I think having that from day one
having that structure
um not just on what good looks like in
terms of numbers like CV send outs and
calls stuff like that but also what what
does good look like in terms of the
attitude you bring to work every day
because a lot of these people have never
worked in an office before they've never
worked in a recruitment firm before so
what you know what the morale and the
motivation and determination you bring
to work every day how do you support
your colleagues with that out of office
like how do you present yourself like in
client meetings Etc all this is in the
Bible so what does performance look like
outside of just your numbers it's
recruitment is more than just a numbers
game it's a mindset thing so yeah I
think having that from day one making
sure because I think people
um well young people especially if
they're new to the role they will kind
of try and push boundaries a little bit
but um you know if you have that
structure and that really kind of clear
expectations from day one then they've
got all The Strokes they need to go and
perform basically I love that so many
recruitment companies don't have that
yeah and I've never had that really I
mean I've had great managers who've
trained me really well but I've never
had that structure and I think you know
everyone's always saying you need to be
more organized like recruiters need to
organize their time better but no one
teaches us how to do that and no one
gives us that structure those systems
those expectations those processes it's
just just figure out and be better again
this is like normal when SAS right yeah
exactly to have those processes in place
and there's a lot more structure I think
because there's people who are more
technically minded that are working as
part of that company and a lot of the
founders so that's just you know there
from from day one whereas recruitment
companies it's more about yeah it's just
a bit all over the place yeah and it's
so like we've got all of ours built in
motion so we use notion and then we've
got a sales Playbook we've got a
customer success Playbook we're building
a marketing Playbook and you know in the
sales Playbook which is where I often
find myself is we've got our most
up-to-date talking tracks you know the
opening to cold calls what we use the
problem statements that we use we've got
our case studies in there we've got you
know the common rejections that we're
running into it's just more of like all
the things that you said and then also
how valuable is it to be able to go
somewhere so Alex has said This is how
we do things this is you know what
really world-class candidate
qualification looks like and also in on
Timothy Bible it's documented for you so
next time when you're coaching me and
you're listening to one of my calls and
you give me a remedy and it's like oh
you know what I could have done that way
better let me go back to like what world
class looks like again and I can refer
back to it use it that's so valuable I
wish I had that in recruitment because
all I got given was a couple of printed
out sheets or candidate qualification
sheets and that's it yeah there's
nowhere for me to go to understand
currently up to date what good looks
like and what's working for people which
is why the Bible the Playbook whatever
you want to use it is a really valuable
thing it takes a lot of upfront time and
effort but then as you said I'm glad you
highlighted that because you've put that
upfront time and effort and that's
clearly been impactful in helping this
time around yeah absolutely and we're
currently in the process of building
like a sales play play with like a BD
Playbook but it's difficult because it's
it's really just me and George but
eventually there's going to be more the
junior Consultants are going to progress
to doing that kind of more client BD
type role so they'll Need A playbook for
that so it's like okay I've got to do
another one now but it's it's worth it
it saves you so much time in the long
run like all the little questions that
they can refer back to there but also I
found it I don't know about your help it
helped me as well like oh yeah I still
look at the book but like actually
creating it helps yeah like it helps you
think about the how you're equipping
your team of how to do things yeah and
that's like way more powerful rather
than like do do it because I've said it
this way yeah yeah and it really gets
you thinking about the heart okay
covered a lot yeah that's awesome yeah
uh look Alex thank you so much for
coming on the podcast you really
articulated things so well there in
terms of breaking things down and I know
there's going to be so many things that
people are going to think hang on a
minute we could maybe implement this or
we could do that so yeah Alex thank you
so much for coming on the Pod well
thanks for having me it's been great
I've had a lot of fun